are you
g actual do you want to check with me
yes Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you will in be reaping the click the
link and donate what you
Canam brothers and sisters and dear
I was Disturbed seeing this video and
I'm sure you guys are going to be as
Disturbed but we're going to go to the
roots of the problem with these kind of
stuff Subhan Allah back in the days
people would hide their shame and like
the prophet Muhammad sallallah alaihi
wasallam said if you have no shame do as
you please to see this happen in Mecca
if I'm not mistaken it's in Medina or
Mecca it's definitely Mecca you just
really like wow like it's it's crazy now
obviously we're not blaming the lands
but there's so much key things for us to
understand people think some people do
Hijra there's nothing wrong with that of
course Muslim lands are much much
hundred times better but it's not to the
lands that you go in tawa is not based
on places you go like Allah says in the
Quran tawa is not facing the east or the
West tawa when Allah talks about
slaughtering animal Allah says it's not
the blood that reaches Allah but rather
it's the takwa when Allah talks about in
the who were building a m Allah said go
to the m of it's better to pray there
and when Allah talks to us about the
clothing that was sent but rather the
clothing of tawa Allah keep talking
about tawa from the clothes that you
wear to the dire ition that you face to
the animal that you Slaughter to the
place that you pray tawa tawa tawa tawa
not places there are people in Mecca
that I was when I was there the cab
drivers who they don't even pray Salah
they don't even they haven't even G
literally there which shows you it
doesn't matter where you are you can
have people who live in the west and
there you know with all this degenerate
degeneracy going on but people hold firm
to their religion and then you have
people who live in Mecca who become
atheist and what you're about to witness
now this is a person and when I watch
this guys let's watch this and get to in
let's talk about the root problem which
is pornography here is what happened to
this young man are you g do you want to
with
me so you live alone in your room
no with my
mom she come back or still in Haram uh
Haram my mom yeah she she has not
written yet good that's good so can you
go up side
my room yeah for what what do you
actually want from
me what do you
think I don't know because I'm not
magician yes you are to the point are
you
g actual do you want to sck with me yes
so if that your attention
please just keep it in your
pen understand I don't want to be among
that
you
angry English please leave me I don't
want to be a
flowery go
yeahum may Allah bless you
I mean like you you just become
speechless I mean would I say may Allah
bless you after someone approach like
should I say may Allah destroy you what
kind of you what kind of animal are you
or may Allah forgive you I mean if if I
had some kind of Mercy I say may Allah
forgive you forget may Allah bless
you you are in Mecca you are approaching
some random guy with no shame at least
somebody would have shame and think you
know what let me try to I mean I don't I
don't know like you know some people if
you have this tenance you would have
some shyness and try to find out someone
maybe who who is like you no he's just
casually approaching people yeah yeah
you know and one thing is very I did
this as well may Allah forgive me when I
watched this cuz I wasn't paying
attention I thought the person who's
showing his face was the one why because
obviously I don't want to fall into
backb he's a Muslim alhamd he's somebody
who fears Allah that he put it's just
because he has a feminine Look to Him
you know it's this is why this is the
third time he was approached by the way
he said that this was was the third time
he was a approach can you imagine it was
the first time he didn't record and the
second and third time he had no choice
about to literally being harassed if
that was me I think I would like this
punch you in the face what what BR you
coming to me like are you okay like
should I slap you what should I do like
how are you where with audacity it's
sickening and this goes back to
pornography this goes back to the
degeneracy and pornography and guess
what brother and sister Subhan Allah
guess who five companies one of them
being I don't want to mention because
people pee hop yes okay who are they
owned by who are they own by let me tell
you who they owned by all of these
companies Subhan Allah who are they
owned by they are owned by someone
called Solan fredman Solan fredman yes
and not only that me companies and who
is he he is a Zionist a Zionist and many
me look what you seeing on the screen
now brother and sisters yeah look Al
Goldstein yes the only reason Jews are
in the pornography is that we
think Christ sucks Catholicism sucks wow
this is the Christians uh Bible
Christians supporting the Jews they you
go this what they think of you yeah Gary
kreman found of sex.com and match.com
Adam glassa king of Gonzo porn these are
all Zionist look check this out you
can't make this stuff up bro Mike kich
monarchy distribution yeah Sam samro um
Nathan Adams I how mention this is uh oh
my gosh um sea rad found off Tinder Ron
Jeremy Greg Lansky uh Joel Sima whatever
his name is yeah David F uh Freeman yes
the trash field King okay Steve
orstein Stefan pad uh roren roren
stman Fabian thilman whatever it's
called all own some kind of a adult
website or some kind of industry and all
of them are Zionist and we Muslims are
the ones that are coming into your lands
and trying to take over with our Sharia
law no IM no muslim is ever allowed to
own or get involved with intimacy sex
outside of marriage let alone owning
these websites that are destroying the
Western World destroying your daughters
and your sons and you think Islam is the
threat these zionists are owning
everything that you have they own they
own it literally unbelievable these
zionists are the ones who are destroying
your Youth and that's what said when you
make the genery sex marriage among
prevent among the youth that Nation will
be destroyed and destruction and this is
one of the signs of the hour
unbelievable in Mecca approaching
another man to go upstairs he's saying
I'm with my mom he's saying let's go say
look at the filth you have to be the
direct approach you have no shame like
the prophet said if you have no shame do
as you please and one of the days of the
one of the signs of hour is what two
people who are committing Z and the best
amongst them will say can you go and do
it behind the wall please that's going
to be the best amongst them may Allah
protect us and our children this is what
we're talking about brother sisters the
degeneracy that is attacking and
pornography is the root cause of all
evil all evil yes there was that guy I
forgot his name who was a serial killer
Ted Bundy who when he was young he saw a
pornography magazine and that changed
him to go and kill killing Spirit of
prostitutes may Allah subhana protect us
unbelievable this shows you again
brother and sisters tawa is not where
you live this man has no fear in the
Holy lands approaching this kind of f
may Allah may Allah subhana tala forgive
us may Allah forgive us may Allah if
this guy has shame to repent it's not
too late well repent whoever you are and
I just I was shocked I was shocked by
this is showing you what dangerous times
we live in may Allah protect
usam the prophet sallallah alhi wasallam
said whoever builds a Masid for the sake
of Allah
Allah will build for him a similar house
in jenah on that day where Allah subhana
tal tells us that our books will be
given and every little atom weight of
Good Deed you've done will be there and
imagine you see a mountain and you're
like what a lucky person which righteous
person and Allah says this is for you
for me yes what did I do you allow
people to pray you built a Masid I never
had the money to build a Masid oh Allah
you helped you gave towards it and Allah
gives you the reward of as if you've
built it donate now guys and do not
delay and share the video for extra
Rewards
[Music]